america's first roller coaster ride
which opened in 1884 at coney island
brooklyn and capable of a top speed of
only six miles per hour
so and then we have the choice e which
is no error so let's think about where
there if there is an error here where it
is
so america's first roller coaster ride
which opened in 1884 at coney island
brooklyn
and capable of a top speed of only six
miles per hour so the way it's written
right now we never even get to knowing
what america's first roller coaster did
both of these clauses which opened in
1884 at coney island brooklyn that's one
that kind of describes america's first
roller coaster and then another clause
and capable of a top speed of only six
miles per hour that also the way it's
written it's still kind of just
describing america's first roller
coaster but it didn't say what it's
actually doing if i were to say where
the error is if i'm trying to convey
this meaning i would have said something
like america's first rollercoaster ride
which opened in 1884 at coney island
brooklyn was capable of a top speed of
only six miles per hour so i would have
changed and capable of i would have
changed this to was capable of
was capable of a top speed of only six
miles per hour so the error here is in
part is in part b